what's up everyone
Warren here and man last night the
Avengers in-game trailer TV spot for the
Super Bowl was awesome
we got way more new footage than I
thought we were going to get I only
thought we were going to get maybe a
scene or two of new footage but for the
most part I thought it was going to be
the old teaser trailer with maybe one or
two new scenes last year for infinity
war it was basically the teaser trailer
with one or two added scenes the one
where Tony Stark and I'd spider-man and
Avenger but we got a lot last night
including something that could have been
very well hidden by the Russo brothers
but something that a lot of people have
picked up on and something that a lot of
people believe to be true and that is
that we heard Ultron in the in-game TV
spot so I'll talk about that in this
video also with the release of the new
TV spot yesterday I started a new
giveaway
Dustin gates was the winner of the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway he has
already claimed it it's on his way to
him and now I'm giving away five imax
tickets to go see Avengers in-game when
it comes out if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like the video
comment down below with your favorite
character that could be a superhero or a
villain and let me know why they're your
favorite so of course in this TV spot
the first words we hear are from Captain
America and he says some people move on
but not us and that's pretty clear but
then he says not us a second time and
it's really distorted and it sounds a
lot like Ultron so let's take a listen
to it
and now let's take a listen to how
ultron sounds i don't have anyone else i
was meant to be new I was meant to be
beautiful it sounds like Ultron it
doesn't sound like Captain America
Captain America just said not us and
then this next not us does not sound the
same
it sounds very distorted and kind of
like a robot now this could be nothing
it could be just for effects for the
trailer but there are some strong
arguments for how Ultron could appear in
Avengers end game but let me clarify if
Ultron is an Avengers in game it will
not be the same Ultron
from Avengers age of Ultron this will be
a newly designed Ultron from Tony Stark
Bruce Banner and Sheree it won't be an
evil Ultron trying to make humanity
extinct again so there's a few things
here one is that the Russo brothers said
that Avengers in game is going to wrap
up the first 10 years story of the MCU
and they also said that we really have
no idea what the actual plot for
Avengers in game is going to be and I
don't think people really expect Ultron
to show up in Avengers in game and if
you refer back to age of Ultron Ultron
is Tony starts in game that up there
that's that's a game how are you guys
planning on beating that and what is
this 10 year story that they're talking
about wrapping up
well it's Tony Stark's in game that's
the story they're wrapping up since the
very first Avengers film when Tony went
through the wormhole he has been working
on a plan for Earth's defense that
doesn't require the Avengers
so Ultron was Tony's in game and
remember he's not dead he was AI
artificial intelligence he wasn't a
person you know that Tony and Bruce have
to have his programming backed up
somewhere and maybe with the help of
Sheree and wakandan technology they can
fix his programming and make it to where
Ultron isn't evil so what would the
point of reviving Ultron be in Avengers
in game well he is supposed to be Tony
Stark's in game but maybe he can design
and program Ultron to be able to absorb
all of the power of the Infinity stones
Tony Stark actually did this before with
a machine called Arsenal and the
Avengers Assemble series he designed a
robot to be able to absorb all of the
power of the Infinity stones
so perhaps an Avengers in game he could
redesign Ultron in a similar way to
absorb the power of the Infinity stones
when they fight Thanos I definitely
don't think they would do it the exact
same way as they did in Avengers
Assemble but it could be a way to help
defeat Thanos again this would wrap up
Tony Stark's story from the very first
Avengers film him trying to find a way
to protect earth without the need for
the Avengers so we know that Ultron was
always intended to be Tony Stark's in
game and now in Avengers in game it
could come to fruition
of course this is all based off of that
voice in the Avengers in game TV spot
trailer being Ultron the Russo brothers
are known for their classic misdirection
with their trailers so they could either
be trying to make it sound like cap just
a little bit different or trying to make
it sound like Ultron just a little bit
different so let me know what you think
do you think this is the voice of Ultron
and if so what do you think about him
possibly returning in Avengers endgame
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe if you're new and comment down
below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to marvel and
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]